[Musique]
sur une île au large des côtes
écossaises une chose a été invoqué des
profondeurs de l'enfer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une chose qui mettrait fin à l'humanité
cette chose qui vous inquiète tellement
elle est là
vous êtes là
du combat toutes les menaces et pourtant
tu m'as recueillis çà va phyto tu as
fait de moi une arme
[ __ ] on va sortir les violons
ecoutez-moi attentivement une sorcière
du vème siècle se promène dans la nature
elle veut anéantir londres et le monde
entier
[Musique]
cool des devoirs
pourquoi te battus aux côtés de ceux qui
craignent et white
c'est ta destinée
descendre
un nouvel éden émergera
ok il y aurait pas une prophétie avec
des enjeux plus clair on va pas sauver
le monde voit un truc comme ça
web on voit les surnoms grand jeu va
dire
ces bons à rien
toi mon roi
nous appartenons l'un à l'autre
ah non attention sa liste de pas
fonctionné nous deux parce que moi je
suis capricorne et toi tu es une [ __ ]
de feu zinc